have you ever run a workload that uses
virtual machines in google cloud and
while you're enjoying a cup of tea
during quick break your alerts are
firing the service is having issues and
users are really unhappy
you rush back to your computer and log
into the cloud console the vms are still
up and system resources are seemingly
normal what can you do to troubleshoot
from here
well you might want to look at a few
things whether your app processes are
running on the vms how much resources
they're consuming and whether there are
any errors in the logs
but as you may remember from our
previous episode
you need to have the ops agent installed
running and collecting and sending data
to get this kind of information from
your vms
if you ever have issues getting
installed running or getting data you've
come to the right place my name is yuri
i'm an sre at google cloud and today i'm
going to show you how to troubleshoot
the alps agent to make sure you always
have the vm observability data you need
and get back to that tee before it gets
cold
let's start at the beginning with the
installation there are two primary
reasons why you might have trouble
getting the agent installed
the first reason is that you're trying
to install it on an unsupported
operating system you'll know that's the
case if you see an error message like
this where the installer isn't able to
download the right package for your os
the second reason is a configuration
conflict specifically with the old
monitoring or logging agents in this
case you'll see an error message like
this one
you can't have both the alps agent and
the old agents installed at the same
time so you'll have to uninstall the old
agents first
once the agent is installed you can
confirm that it's running by using the
system cdl status command like this and
looking for the confirmation messages
that the agent components are started
and running
if the agent is not running you may need
to start it if it has issues starting
you may have a conflict or an invalid
configuration let's have a look at how
to start the agent and sort out startup
issues
if the agent isn't running for any
reason you'll see a message like this
saying that the service isn't running
when you check its status
use the start command to try to get it
running again
you might get a message like this saying
that either the cloud ops agent itself
or one of its modules failed to start
the former usually means you have an
invalid configuration
have a look at the documentation on how
to configure the agent to sort this out
we'll of course link to it in the
episode notes
if a module can't start it's likely
because it can't send logs or metrics to
the api often this is caused by invalid
credentials such as a disabled service
account or an expired key networking
issues and proxy issues such as an
invalid proxy configuration can also
cause this
once you verify that the agent is
installed and running you should be
getting its metrics and logs ingested if
that's not the case you'll need to
figure out why
generally you'll be investigating three
types of issues the first has to do with
the agent itself the second is with the
sources of data you're trying to ingest
and the third is with sending collected
data to the respective api let's have a
look at each
if the issue you're seeing has to do
with logs check to see if the logging
module is running like this if the
output is anything other than successful
you may need to restart the agent or
validate its configuration
if the logging module is running the
next thing to check is whether it's able
to read the logs one way to check is to
use the local metric standpoint like
this
if everything looks good so far but
you're still not seeing the logs you
expect check to see if the agent is
getting any errors from the logging api
you can do that in the logging module
log like this you might see permission
errors if the api isn't enabled in the
project the service account has been
disabled or doesn't have the right
permissions the service account key
expired or if the agent is using the
vm's default service account
insufficient scopes on the vm itself you
might also be out of quota for the api
you'll need to resolve these to resume
log ingestion
we'll use a similar approach to
troubleshoot the metrics module let's
have a look
you can check the status of the metrics
module by looking at module logs in
syslog if there aren't any logs the
service may not be running properly
otherwise you can check the logs
themselves to see if there are any
issues noted there
this log is also where you would check
for any api errors such as permission
denied or quota issues
at this point you should have everything
you need to sort out agent issues and
never be in the dark about your vms
running on google cloud
thanks so much for watching today don't
forget to like and subscribe to never
miss out on more engineering for
reliability with google cloud see you
soon
[Music]